[Music]
straight down here
you good
i need to go to the restroom if we have
a second
and i'll grab my kids um
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
now
is
[Music]
space
gather up oh my mic's on
hello welcome to the table but dawn's
gonna do that part
good evening
welcome to the table thank you brett for
that improv introduction that we just
had
uh so glad to see you guys this evening
and we appreciate those of you are able
to join us online um it's great that you
guys are here and present you're very
much a part of this family as well
um so before we get started i do have
like several
announcements for you guys to kind of
keep up with so next sunday and i know
we've been kind of mentioning this but
next sunday we're not having service
we're just kind of taking a little bit
of a break especially for all our our
visit our volunteers our leadership
folks just kind of take a little bit
break a little bit of breather um i know
that the summer is about to kick off
with kids not having school so that's
also a nice little thing for you guys to
spend time with family so
just kind of no no service next week
but then next month kicks off uh pride
month and so dallas yeah
dallas pride is the first weekend in
june so as the table community to kind
of help support um we are actually going
to be part um do uh participate with the
fireworks
and be present during the firework show
that that particular
day so the pride event is actually a two
day events a saturday sunday uh event
it's at fair park um so um so it's very
kid-friendly and all that kind of stuff
for you guys to assembly bring families
and
to participate in that
but as the uh table family
we are going to basically
meet at the smith fountain um
smith fountain which is inside of the
gate 4
and so around 8 p.m
and then the fireworks
is going to start around 9pm so just
kind of keep that in the back of your
mind as well
another announcement is uh we're going
to a child dedication
um yes we love our kids love our kids um
that is uh june 19th that's going to
actually be a coincide with father's day
which is kind of an easy way to kind of
remember that um so just kind of know
that during that time we are going to
have a child's dedication this is just a
great time to just kind of focus on our
kids that we're going to raise them in a
way that you know we just want them to
love jesus and so that's just a good way
of doing that we're in you know dedicate
all of our families um at that time so
that's something you're interested in um
you can do that there's cards in the
back like we use our visitor cards you
can notate that that's that's something
you must simply want to participate in
um those of you who are joining us
online there's a way that you if you
would mention that either on our
facebook group page or you just kind of
go to the website and then just kind of
you know message us we'll make sure that
you um we'll keep you in the loop and
how to participate with that as well
okay did you guys write all that down
because there's going to be a quiz
at the end of this i may not remember
actually you pass it that's what i want
to know
i didn't have the notes in front of me i
might not remember all this either
okay um so as a call to worship we've
had like a lot of just
just challenging things that have
happened um in our world especially with
um
just some shootings have occurred um
and it's just it's kind of hard
not knowing exactly where to be it's
hard
for people mentally emotionally um
just to kind of because the the
situation is just is challenging um
anytime that we hear stuff like that um
it's heartbreaking um
obviously that could be anywhere that
could happen to anybody
at any time
um and so
people must definitely have strong
opinions about those kinds of things
and
my biggest thing is that we just kind of
focus on what is it that our response
should be
especially as believers in christ people
who love jesus
um
what how should we partic particularly
you know being that and so we properly
want you to be active in something like
that on how you should respond to those
kinds of things
so as we can kind of get ready for
worship i just want to lead you in a
prayer
it's not going to le it's not going to
hopefully not
not replace any kind of actions you
might want to take
but just kind of prepare us in a
spiritual space
for something like that
so pray for me please
lord god
we pray that you find a way as mature
disciples of jesus
to end gun violence
and we pray and support those
those of us whose lives have been
touched by gun violence
and we pray for and support mental
health professionals
who are in front lines of this work
and we pray for and support our
legislators
who can pass meaningful and common sense
legislation to stem the tide of violence
and oh god we
hope you heal us from hate that's within
and draw us
all people to yourself
amen
thank you don
well i'm really glad that you guys are
all with us tonight i hope that you feel
like there's space in room for your
story and who you are
and that's not just for the adults in
there that's also for our kids that are
in the room
all of these lovely people right up here
a lot of them right here the front
um i want to invite you guys into the
space i know that we started having you
guys stay with us in the first song i
don't know if y'all know that we
actually want you to like engage this
time with us it's not just like a
babysitting time where you need to sit
there
and you know just wait till you get
dismissed but it's actually a time for
all of us as a community to worship
together
so as we stand to worship i just invite
you guys to be in the space with us and
worship for me is a time to
engage the creative
peace of my heart in something that can
open me up to what god might want to
speak to me or maybe a sense of love a
sense of community and you guys have
that ability even better than we do as
adults you kids are so much better at
about opening up your heart and being
vulnerable so i just invite you guys to
make this space your own as well engage
in worship with us um so sometimes that
looks like us opening our hands
sometimes that looks like raising our
arms sometimes it looks like standing
still and closing our eyes and being
quiet and just
being in the moment so i just wanted to
kind of lay that groundwork for you kids
who are in the service with us some of
you for the first time you are welcome
here in the space and we want you guys
to worship with us because god can speak
to you just like he can speak to us all
right so um i invite you kids to think
about what god might want to say to you
some of you boys right there on the
front row think about what god might be
saying to you hey guys
all right
so we're gonna start josh is gonna kick
us off with father's house so y'all
engaged this time open our hearts and um
let's see what he might be speaking all
right
let's do it
[Music]
sometimes on this journey
i get lost
[Music]
my story isn't over
my story's just
[Music]
that's what my father does
here in the father's house
check your shame at the door
the city welcome
house
[Music]
is
and the story isn't over
the story is okay
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you're in the father's house
love is on the move
[Music]
here we go
miracles take place
the love is breaking through
when the father
jericho walked away again
strongholds now are shaking
love is breaking through
me and the father's in the room
[Music]
[Applause]
the father's house
[Music]
sitting welcoming
you're in the father's house
[Music]
all right
yeah
thank you guys you kids are dismissed to
go to kids ministry and we'll see you
all later
[Music]
for the resurrection
that we waited for
we came with the night
and came with the
morning you're the king of heaven
all the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder the core
[Music]
a new song
seth is dead and gone with the winner
we will sing a new song
hallelujahs flow like the river
from coming back to life
reaching towards the light your love is
like springtime
[Music]
[Applause]
god we thirst for you
[Music]
the dry and the baron
will flower
[Music]
we will sing a new song
death is dead and gone with the winner
like the river
we're coming back
reaching towards the light
your love is like springtime
[Music]
like a garden
and like a garden i will grow
i will grow
[Music]
and like a garden i will
i will go
[Music]
we will sing a new song
reaching towards
[Music]
coming is to life
reaching towards the light
your love is like springtime
[Music]
now
would you guys pray this out loud with
me
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
so now we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
the fires around new mexico
[Applause]
[Music]
jaiden
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i'm thinking of several of us
in this community that
are going through
a bunch of trying things with either
parenting relationships
or loss grief
and
this song in particular is
really encouraging us to be in a posture
of opening up and vulnerability
and i know that can be hard when we feel
especially guarded
or exhausted
or
challenged
but what i love about god is that he is
always a safe space for us
never looking for a moment to take
advantage of us never looking for a
pushy way in
but always there waiting
patient
long-suffering
good
kind
never shaming
so i just invite you into this space
where you can be vulnerable
where you can lay out your needs
where you can open up your heart
maybe only with him maybe there's no one
else you feel safe enough to open up
with
but he is safe
[Music]
i am trusting that you are a faithful
father
and all that you have is good
[Music]
won't you come and break through
hey
to me
[Music]
that builds
up you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
over and over and over again i am
and again
and over again i am bringing my heart to
you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing end as
the depths of my heart lay before you
again
[Music]
we make room for you
cause you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece
[Music]
god thank you for being safe
thank you that every time
we find you we are met with love
with forgiveness
with kindness
you're never waiting to jump down our
throats
[Music]
but you're always calling us tomorrow
always calling us deeper into who you
made us to be
always calling us back to your original
design your creation
beautiful
wholly loved
[Music]
god
you are the one who knows us best
you are the one who hemmed us in before
and behind
you saw what you were making and you
called it good
[Music]
would we have eyes to see that
would we adopt your perspective
would we invite you in
to walk this out with us
[Music]
when we're so good at trying to do it on
our own
and take control
god would we trust
that you're a good father
[Music]
that all that you have for us is good
you are faithful you will complete the
work of your hand
[Music]
we love you jesus
we welcome you into this time and the
space with us thank you for the gift of
community the gift of worshiping
together the gift of church
and when it's at its best it's a
reflection of you
and your heart
your justice
your
redemption
your sacrificial love
so let us embody those things together
it's in your name i pray
amen
[Music]
thank you guys
sit down and turn to the people around
you and if you don't know them ask them
their name say hello if you do know them
welcome them into this space and then
brett will get us started with the
message
all right all right if we get those
lights up
um
good evening
grace and peace welcome to the table how
are y'all doing
doing well
hanging in there
good good good
um
well it's a joy to be with all of you
and as always that includes those
joining us online saw eric on i saw adam
on
and uh so good to be with you and and
anyone else who was there that maybe was
hadn't commented or something uh welcome
and also anyone here who's new or you
know first second third fourth time just
kind of find your way in thank you um
thanks for being here
so
let's see we are continuing on in our
series actually we have this message
it's like our break next week because we
won't be meeting and then the following
we'll do one more message in first peter
part three then we'll hit the pause
button do a different series i think
something about hearing god i don't know
we'll see we'll feel it out and uh and
then we'll kind of come back later so um
we got two more in in this this section
so um the title of the message tonight
is what's my purpose
what's my purpose and as we get into it
you'll see i mean this in a very big
sense not necessarily like i don't know
what job should i work you know but like
a much bigger broader thing um so our
text is first peter chapter 4
verses 7 through 11
which says this the end of all things is
near
therefore be alert and of sober minds
that you may pray
above all love each other deeply
because love covers over a multitude of
sins
offer hospitality to one another without
grumbling
each of you should use whatever gifts
you have received to serve others as
faithful stewards of god's grace in its
various forms
verse 11 if anyone speaks they should do
so as one who speaks the very words of
god if anyone serves they should do so
with the strength god provides so that
in all things god may be praised through
jesus christ to him be the glory and the
power forever and ever
amen
so um i want to focus in on that that
opening line
uh where
peter names he says the the end of all
things um is near
and um this is uh it's i mean it's an
interesting um
section because i think you know
initially when you hear like the idea of
the end you know or i don't know if you
saw like someone on the side of the road
with a cardboard sign
that says the end of all things is near
you know or the end is near like that's
you kind of getting a certain image of
you know like uh an apocalyptic
hellscape with ashes and fire
and you know it's like someone who yeah
it's like life has been rough and so
it's like the end is near you know i
mean judgment day this is kind of what
we hear you know i mean we read
something like that and he opens but the
end is near we're like oh my gosh this
guy peter he's
so pessimistic
and um
i think uh i think that's actually not
such a good reading of um
what peter's actually um getting at
because um the greek word here as you
can see on the screen is um the word
telos that's the word translated into
most of your english bibles as um end
and telos is a it's a very rich word um
telos can mean um aim
end goal or purpose
and uh so in other words i think what
what peter's naming here is is less of
an emphasis on
you know
the dystopian
hellscape judgment of fire is is about
to come upon you so turn or burn you
know or something i don't i don't think
i think that's kind of importing certain
readings of the book of revelation
combined with maybe some other ideas we
have about the end
and um and kind of bringing that and
kind of infusing that into peter and
kind of putting that on peter and we'll
get into i do think he has some notion
of kind of judgment and such kind of
happening but um
i i think that's it's a it's a much
richer
and i think honestly in ways more
beautiful
um
uh
uh kind of thing peter's trying to to
get at
um and so that's kind of what my message
is i want to kind of un unpack on what
this might be
because um
i think what what peter is naming is
when he says the the telos of all things
is near
um is
is not so much you know you and all
things are about to come to a quick end
but um something more like um
[Music]
when when you ask the question um what
end
have i been created for
that what telos have i and all things
been created for i think that's actually
more accurate to what peter's getting at
and here's what i mean um for example if
you think of like um you know an author
right who writes a story
and it's very important that the author
have some sense of the telos of their
story in mind which is a richer idea
than just well they need to know how
this thing wraps up
can you see how it's a richer idea than
that because in other words what they
need to know is okay
to what end
is my story driving not just how's this
thing gonna wrap up but
why the heck am i writing this
right that's a richer thing then do you
know how your story's gonna end like oh
yeah i think i do i have something
really clever
you know in other words you can know
your end
and yet not really have a good end
not really have a good aim
goal
purpose
right it's a it's in many ways it's
about trajectory where are you headed
right that's what the author has to know
where are these characters headed
and
how will i get them where they need to
go in other words how do they my
characters need to grow and develop and
mature to what end
are they headed right can you start to
get a little bit how that's a richer
thing than like so what's the what's the
ending of them
right it's it's that's telos the telos
of all things is near
the very goal the very aim the very
purpose
of god and all creation is is near that
tell us that we've been driving towards
that your whole life has been pointing
towards peter's saying it's like it's
coming near every step every day you're
aimed towards it
um
another example could be uh teaching we
have a few teachers um here at the table
and um
you know a good teacher always has to
know
like have a telos
right have um
a certain um aim and goal purpose in
mind which is of course again different
than a good teacher always has to know
when the last day of school is
all right even though i know we do have
teachers and some students that are very
excited about that last day of school we
got some homeschool mamas that are also
very excited about that last day all
right so but but what i'm naming is more
than just you know the last day of
school um i'm saying right to to under
because in other words you're asking um
what the heck it's the question every
kid i assume every kid ever has asked
why
are we here
why do i have to go to school
right this anyone heard this question
anyone asked this question as a kid like
yes all of us right like and what are we
what are they asking what are we asking
in that moment
tell us
tell us purpose aim end goal where where
are we headed with all this this is a
lot of time and energy
where are we headed right and so a good
teacher has a sense for the tell us of
education in general and even of that
school year in particular like
where are we going
and um and of course this is probably
going too long on education but it's a
passion of mine right so um even with
education there's a lot of debate
honestly if you go and get your master's
or phd in education a lot of what you
start getting into
um at least in some classes is exactly
this tell us
purpose
right and there's quite the debate
around like is the purpose of education
is it um to prepare kids for the job
market
is that like the big picture thing like
that's what this is about
or is that like a part of it but there's
like some bigger
telos
purpose
um
like for example um character
who you are becoming
that can you see how like that's like oh
okay wait what are we doing where
where what's our end right in other
words um
you can basically i think hopefully you
can start to see why this kind of
matters
you know like this is kind of it's kind
of a big deal for for us um for an
author to tell us of their story a
teacher to understand to tell us of
education um
uh and even like an organization a
business a church right to name your
tell us to name this is the end towards
which we are driving
uh that that is incredibly powerful
partly beak and here's why because um
you
i mean there's probably a lot of reasons
but at least one reason is that you
can't really judge
um
where you are today
accurately unless you know the end for
which you've been created
right and this is true by the way of all
nouns
person places things
um
until you know the purpose the telos of
a thing you and no you are in no place
to judge it um for example i was
imagining um this week this grand piano
right over here and of course a piano
has a telos doesn't it
right it was the maker
created it
with a certain purpose
right and um
we know and so this is why there's like
good questions to ask of a piano you
know like good question would be um are
its tones rich in deep
that'd be a good question or uh how
responsive are its keys are they sticky
i know that travis my wife teaches piano
stripes are bananas of a sticky keys you
know so those those would be good
questions to ask of a piano
however
if someone
pointed that piano and said
by the way that table is the worst table
because last week
we had a church meal and we tried to use
that table to eat on and it was awful
you can see the position of its legs are
all on the outside
the legs are right in the way of where
your chair's supposed to be and then
it's so tall
that it's like you're up here trying to
eat
and it's just the it's the worst table
don't eat at that table and if they said
that you would look at them like they
are an idiot right and you would be like
what are you
that's not a freaking table man
that's an amazing expensive grand piano
right can you see where if you
misunderstand the telos everything like
you just completely misjudge it right
you're in no place to say like well
that's a good table that's that's not if
it's not a table at all
right okay you're tracking it so
so why does this matter for us um
because here's the thing it's not only
um specific roles that have a telos you
know teacher
author it's not only things or places
that have a telos
people
you
human beings
have
a telos
in fact the bible would say all of
creation
has a telos
an aim an end a goal of purpose
and
until you understand what that is
you um
well honestly this is this is kind of
the state of the modern world there's i
won't go into like a whole history that
would be too nerdy but there's some
books you can read on after virtue by
alistair mcintyre um a number of books
where they basically chart that a few
hundred years ago the modern western
world we let go of the idea of a human
telos
right and part of this was the kind of
letting go of god and religion in
general it was just sort of like
we don't know about all that and so what
happens is suddenly when you let go the
idea of a telos well at first there was
a certain liberation like ah we are a
little bit of nietzsche who is like
we're free to create our own lives and
do whatever we want you know and it was
sort of like a little bit euphoric like
yes this is gonna be awesome you know
we're free free of god you know free of
some
purpose put on you you know i mean and
um
but what happened will you play that out
over a few hundred years and you have
what we live in today which is
a absolute crisis of meaning and purpose
because we're like we're like sailors on
the high seas
without a north star
we're just sort of
floating
right we're like characters in a story
that like we don't even know is it a
story is this just random crap happening
right can you see this like
this is sort of the world is where we've
we've lost our telos and actually
aleister mcintyre's point is once you
lose that he basically says um our whole
sense of right and wrong what is um like
virtue you know like what's the good
it is completely based on telos
right why is that good why
why is that thing bad who are you to say
well without a telos
oh
i don't know you just have opinion you
just have opinion which is basically the
state of the western world like it's
just so it's basically whoever screams
the loudest about what they think they
at least for the moment they went you
know but there's no like logic to it
there's no rationale there's no really
argument to be built on of like let me
let me explain why
that is the good because it's because
here's our tell here's the end goal
here's what it means to be a good human
being here's what it means to live into
your purpose right here is your purpose
like can you see where this would be
kind of a big deal
and so i think this is really the the
beauty and the genius of the word tell
us it's a good word that tell us of all
things is drawing near
so so what would what would it be
um i'm speaking out as a christian
of course
pastor church that makes sense
but i'm not saying this is only to tell
us of christians
because that's actually that's kind of
the whole point
we need good dialogue
of like what is it for us as humans what
does it mean to be a good human
what are we doing as humans
right and what can we unite around so so
here's based on i'm drawing on a number
of things from jesus when he was asked
what's the most important thing to um
just the scriptures in general and even
this passage as we'll see
but i want to name kind of what i think
kind of is our human tell-offs um so
here it is our whole life
is a process of learning to
give receive and grow in here's the key
word
love yes
that's the key word right i don't know
however you want to phrase it give
receive i don't know i'm not like sold
on that exact language but basically
what is your telos
love
love love love this why because who is
god
like who did you come from
you're like my mom well kind of but i
mean in like a
bigger sense right you've been you've
been birthed from love you came from
love
from god you've come
and and so what is your telos where are
you going
well not somewhere else
right or like i don't know no from love
you came
and
to love you return to love you're going
like this
right and so it makes sense that like
if god
created all that is
right from the god who is love that's
this is where i say i'm speaking as a
christian right um
so god who is love if that's where you
came from and then that is your tell us
that's the very purpose the end that's
the end of all things where do all
things end up where do us and all things
it's like we return to god we return to
love and so it makes sense that in the
meantime
what are we doing here
what are we doing
we're growing
we're growing in love we're maturing in
love we're learning and it's hard right
this is not easy if you're like oh i
already did that i already learned how
to do that it's like i don't think you
really understand
this is like a lifetime
a lifetime you know and definitely it's
the uh two steps forward one step back
you know you ever tried to love well
because of course i'm talking about much
more here than like romantic look
falling in love right if you think
that's exactly what i mean like no no i
mean this in a much richer sense
actually we'll get into some of what
love means but um
this and i want to draw on first peter
here um i want to leave that text too
far behind
so my professors from seminary would be
disappointed in me uh so verse 8 above
all what does he say
love
love each other deeply all right the
tell us that the end
very that towards which you've been
created your whole life's been pointing
towards it you're moving towards it or
it's moving towards you whatever
spatial metaphor you want to use
it's drawing near and so he says above
all
above anything else love
love love each other deeply
love each other deeply to give to
receive to grow in love
um
now
i i mentioned that there's you know some
sense of like uh
i don't know there is a little bit of uh
i don't know if the word right word is
judgment i realize that word kind of
shivers through people you know a little
bit like a judgment church and it's a
long history there um
but i do think there's there's an
element of he uses the language of um be
of sober mind that's his language in
verse seven therefore right the end of
all things are near
therefore he's like sober up and he
doesn't just mean like stop you're
drinking you know he means in a broader
sense of like the opposite of when
you're drunk and you're like you sink
below thinking and you're like i just
want to check out i just want to pay
attention i just kind of want to be out
of here and you know so he's like
wake up please
wake up sober up
the the very purpose of your life is
here and we've seen it revealed
in god and the god we've come to see in
jesus christ his life is that this
resurrection the whole thing reveals the
god who is love this is what's going on
he's like so wake up sober up and so you
can feel right you feel a little bit of
hopefully kind of good but like little
anxiety or like a you know i don't mean
it in a negative sense but in the like
oh okay oh yes i i need to wake up here
i need to i need to get on purpose
there's a it comes to mind the the movie
tree of life has this wonderful phrase i
think it's i think they're quoting
dostoyevsky though um
and the line is uh maggie's uh laughing
at my desk i love that dostoevsky um but
the line is um
uh love everything
every leaf
every ray of light
if you do not love
your life will flash by
what's that really name it's tell us
it's purpose
and there can be a sense in which
you can miss it
you can miss it now i say this
i i think at the end end of all things i
think judgment the language like hell in
the bible things like that i think
that's a step
on the path
um partly because i think uh well
there's a whole theology there won't get
into it tonight i'll say it's a moment
um but i think at the end
i think
uh
god wins
god loves god draws us all and all
things
to um ultimate healing
um
but
but there is a little so he's be sober
minded wake up why why would that um
why would that be you know i think we've
kind of gotten caricatures of this a
little bit in christianity you know
where
we've said like you know the end is near
and so
um i don't know we've done little things
like you know at the end of all things
like god's you know you're gonna stand
for the judgment seat you know and uh
god's gonna ask you a question and i
think it's the key i
where i get sideways with
certain folks theology is what what's
the question
because what people say is you know it's
something like well
did you receive jesus christ there's a
personal lord and savior and asked me to
forgive you of all your sins did you
walk the aisle
or
or not did you not
if you didn't
well then it's gonna go very bad for you
right and then of course people ask you
never a question well what about someone
who like never heard the name of jesus
right and they show up and they're like
oh what's the what's the question
they're like did you receive jesus as
your personal lord and savior like jesus
who what you didn't off to hell and
damnation with you right just the whole
thing strikes me as
i just
slightly a little bit silly um so i but
i think but there's still a sense of
judgment there's still a sense of
accountability for you've been created
from love your purpose was love like and
i get the language of judgment in the
bible i'm not trying to shy away from
that jesus talks about it right so i
think what's the question i here's my
i'm speculating a little bit though i
will have some scripture for in a second
i think here's a good question how did
you laugh
how did you love
not did you know all the correct
theological propositions about god and
redemption and did it you know i mean
like
how did you love
i said where is that in the bible well i
think it's kind of everywhere i mean i
think of matthew 25
you know one of my famous passages quote
dostoyevsky in matthew 25 all the time
and uh remember the story right i won't
go into the whole thing it'd be too long
there's jesus right he says at the end
of all things like the son of man
um
we'll stand in all all the nations
everyone will stand before him you know
and he says i'm gonna divide people
um to the sheep and the goats if you
remember the story and it's good to be a
sheep and it's not great to be a goat
and you ask well what is the basis of
such a division because he basically
says right like uh
you know enter in to the sheep and
depart from me to the goats this by the
way gets into the whole theology and the
moment and right there's a whole
elaborate thing there but just for now
let's just sit with us right sheep that
goes
and now you ask well what is the basis
for that on what basis and jesus doesn't
say well it's those who accepted me as
their personal lord and savior you know
he doesn't say that remember what he
says
i was hungry
did you feed me
i was thirsty
give me something to drink
i was a stranger
someone outside your little circle of
care
you welcomed me
i was sick
you took care of me i was in prison
alone
and you visited me and the people both
the sheep and the goats both say ah
we're so sorry sir but no we actually
can almost promise we never saw you not
one time and what does he say what you
did to the least of these my brothers
and sisters
you did to me
i think that is the heartbeat of
christian
living
right the heart of christian faith is
god is love as revealed in the life the
death the
resurrection of jesus christ it's the
heart but the expression how does it
look
it's our tell us
purpose
what are we doing here we're learning to
love
we're learning to love we're learning to
this is what we're doing
towards the the end um
peter gives of just a few i'll spend
just a few minutes on this as we close
just a little like little snippets
little insights i love it because it's
like very practical because you might
wonder like what is that's a very big
tell-off you know i've got to learn to
love oh gosh how do i do that you know
well i mean matthew 25 is a good start
but peter unpacks some things too
verse 8 above all love each other deeply
he says because love covers over a
multitude of sins
it's an interesting phrase i don't think
he means
love
sweeps
a thousand
evil deeds and injustices under the rug
i don't i don't think that's what he's
saying i don't think he's saying love
hides from hard things
you know
no what's he talking about i'm
interpreting here i think it's
forgiveness
it's my guess
love it just
just
covers
just covers
and boy we need a lot of forgiving
in our life and world don't we my
goodness gracious we're a mess
me too
i'm a big mess
so how will we ever make it how we ever
do this how will in any marriage any
friendship any church any how whatever
love
love has expressed in forgiveness you
might sum it up like this i'm living
into my telos to the degree that i'm
learning to love i'm learning to love to
the degree that i'm learning to forgive
that's you under what does it mean to
love how would i ever do such a that's
very lofty like well
forgiveness
second verse nine he says offer
hospitality to one another without
grumbling
that's hospitality it's that circle of
care
thing you know um
i think in the west we tend to just
focus on our family
all right we have our nuclear family and
that's who we care about that's who we
love
um and that's a pretty small little
world you know it's not bad i'm not
saying don't love your family obviously
love your family yes love your your
partner kids or whatever but
but then expand it right this is the
christian faith is about expanding
that circle of care remember jesus words
what you did to the least of these
that's i think endlessly
interpretable and interesting and
challenging who are the least of these
it's like it's often whoever we don't
want to really love
whoever makes us more than a little
uncomfortable
you know like we don't want those people
in
in our church in our community in our
country in our in our you know
yeah that's like um antichrist
because what's christian faith about
it's expanding that circle
expanding that circle of care might say
it like this i'm learning to love to the
degree that i'm learning to practice
hospitality to expand my circle of care
finally finally peter says in verse 10
um each of you should use whatever gift
you have received to serve
others
i love the simplicity of that because
again you might be a little intimidated
by like love how am i going to learn to
love you and yet it's as simple as like
do you have a gift
any gift at all
wonderful don't just use it for you
serve
like that's a beautiful expression of
love just i'm
good at something let me use it for
others
so forgiveness
hospitality
service
that's
what it means to love you couple that
with some matthew 25
well on your way
well on our way
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
i want it to be a moment where we just
remember again our telos our purpose
and where we refocus on jesus we take in
the bread symbolizing his body we take
in
the cuff
symbolizing his bloodshed for us
and it's a moment where we're
remembering
who jesus was
and is
in his life
of
love
his hospitality his forgiveness his
service and then we orient on that and
then we're commissioned we're sent out
to go and do likewise
so we practice what's called an open
table here i mean if you're here tonight
and you want to participate then you're
welcome to to do that um to come forward
so uh let me invite you with this celtic
christian invitation to the table this
is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
in you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
mm-hmm
so
foreign
[Music]
so
this last song is called belovedness and
you may have heard it once before jesse
led it for us but as we were talking
about
the message prep for this week and kind
of what one to play
um
the words of this song just are pointed
back towards
you can
kind of get everything else
right
but until you get this whole
acceptance of god's love
right the rest of it just can't really
fall into place you know like at the end
of the day it's got to start with this
acceptance of
i'm loved
i'm his
he's enough you know there's grace
and
uh
and it's after that that we build
all the other things on it you know it
starts with owning his love for us what
he's done for us that's our beginning
just like brett was saying where are you
from love
believing that
living that way you know that's where we
start
our journey not where we end it
so
you guys are welcome to just sit back
and um listen to the words so come in
[Music]
you want your fear
and all yourself loathing
you've owned the voices inside of your
head
you've owned the shame and reproach of
your failures
it's time to earn your beloved
[Music]
you want your past
and how it's defined you you've owned
everything
everybody else says
it's time to hear what your father has
spoken
it's time to
your
[Music]
beloved and he says you're mine
i smiled when i made you i find you
beautiful in every way
my love for you
is fierce and unending
i'll come to find
[Music]
you see
and he says you're mine
i smiled when i made you i find you
beautiful and happy blake
my bathroom
is fierce and unending
i'll come to fight you
whatever
[Music]
you are completely
love it believe
he
died to
make your
[Music]
and i find you beautiful
in every way
my love for you
[Music]
is whatever it takes
he says you're mine
i smiled when i made you
i find you beautiful
in every
[Music]
whatever it takes
it's time to own
your beloved
[Music]
oh thank you worship team that was that
was great um
just a couple of reminders again uh next
sunday we're not we're not gonna be here
so please don't show up because the
doors won't be open the lights will be
off enjoy that time with your families
um and then just as also if you're a
visitor um
we would love to hear from you uh there
are cards as you exit the door where you
can actually fill out some information
we just love to hear about you and your
time here
also if you are
would love to support ministry you can
do that also by
giving your donation also in those boxes
and you can also do that online as well
so if you would please stand
i'd like to send you out with this
blessing
so you
are a child of god
you
and this is true on your best day
and it's true
on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
all is yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and unconditional love
to everyone you come in come to contact
with
[Music]
thank you
i'm